[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of euphoria season two episode
six as always directed and written by
sam levinson so i'm going to break this
review down into two parts we'll
actually start with all the story that
isn't rue's story and we'll finish off
with rue's story so we get a lot of good
rue narration here guiding us through
all the other stories in this episode
and it starts off talking about nate
that he's more concerned he hasn't
gotten any calls from maddie than
getting like 38 calls from cassie now
what i love they're doing with maddie in
this episode is i like when she has the
tape in her hand she's laying on her bed
that is this overhead shot they use a
lot with maddie but here it really works
because it's showing you she's in the
power position at this point the episode
but by the end of the episode after she
has this awful encounter with nate she's
in that same overhead shot but she's
crawling in this ball crying and it's
just showing you how still this
character of nate affects everybody in
really bad ways what's important too is
that when maddie is talking on the phone
with cat about hypothetically and then
almost sounding very serious about
actually plotting to murder cassie this
seems like a misdirect to me that it's
making the audience think that maddie
would actually do something this which
we definitely thought before the episode
but that it's setting up later on she's
gonna have this conversation with the
person she babysits for played by minka
kelly samantha because you're like if
they cast mika kelly you're wondering
okay why is she in such a small role
well now we see she's in this important
role of samantha because she has this
big scene with maddie in that i think
it's a misdirect about maddie's
character and that it's showing us that
maddie might look at cassie a little
differently after this conversation with
samantha because samantha's someone she
likes and respects and samantha is
someone who says she was in the shoes of
cassie and that she had done the same
thing but she speaks almost as a voice
of cassie to the audience and to maddie
saying her friends guy that she hooked
up with gave her just the right amount
of attention the right time i was a mess
in high school in college just was
shocked someone was even into me so it's
not justifying what cassie did it's not
justifying what samantha did but it's
showing you the mindset and how it might
not be this malicious attack on your
best friend and again it sounds so much
like cassie the way samantha talks
describing herself younger and we're
seeing cassie's almost like a young
samantha in that story so this might
change now maddie's perception of the
whole situation and i do think this
episode with how nate treat her at the
end there is gonna start really turning
the tide towards maybe maddie's gonna
direct her anger about everything that
screwed her over to the real villain
here which is nate which we'll get more
into about nate but speaking of cat who
she was on the phone with you know cat
this season really is just not likeable
at all and that's really shown in this
scene here with how she treats ethan and
how she ends up going about you know
attempting to break up with him and that
it sets up ethan actually breaking up
with her because she lies and says she
has a terminal brain disorder and ethan
sees right through this i mean what did
ethan do to deserve any of this it's
really weird behavior by cat and it's
just contributing to a really just lame
duck storyline for her this season where
it was she was such a fascinating
character in season one and they've just
really threw it away now i'm not someone
who feeds into rumors but there are
rumors that her and sam levinson butted
heads on set about her story i mean it
would make sense because you're seeing
the product you're getting with her
story that's very weak and that she is
so unlikable but again rumors are rumors
that's what they are that could be
totally false but what we're seeing
which isn't a rumor is that this
storyline of catholic season just kind
of stinks now we go to this storyline
here with cassie lexi at their house
with the mom susie who's one of my least
favorite characters i also have some
problems with how they're writing this
character of susie i didn't get to
mention because i didn't review the
first couple episodes but i didn't like
earlier in the season how odd and
strange it was that she's these two
girls mother and when cal was
interrogating them earlier in the season
she didn't do anything she just let this
guy intimidate her children in front of
her then she does do the right thing by
getting rid of these knives in this
episode giving them to lexi because
she's like i don't want cassie doing
something stupid right she knows a state
of mind her daughter's in but this same
woman ends up putting her daughter down
in this episode and the bizarre line to
me was her saying that rue has it rough
and it's strange because like is this
the stuff you want to be saying to your
daughter right now in the state of mind
she is yeah she's giving her the hard
truth cassie about what she did but
again not the right time you know you
should be more concerned about your
daughter's well-being at this moment
that she is suicidal and you're treating
it so casually but the writing's weird
because a second ago she's removing
knives from the kitchen so she's not
treating it casually so i don't know i
just whether it's a writing issue or not
i don't like this character and i would
like a little more explanation of why
she does what she does but what i did
like from these scenes is sydney sweeney
again just showing her range she's an
incredible actress i've been covering
shows she's in since handmaid's tale
sharp objects she's amazing and
everything and i'm happy she's finally
getting her big recognition and she just
again kills it here in this scene with
her crying and screaming it's so good
it's so real now i've given the show a
lot of praise you've seen that my last
two reviews but i still have a lot of
issues in this episode and i'm gonna say
them when i feel it's happening
unfortunately in this here i really
didn't like when roo's narration is
talking about lexi's having second
thoughts about her play because of how
it'll affect cassie i like that that's
all in great makes sense in the story
what i don't like is all of a sudden
lexie's at fezz's place right now
lexi and fez this is the couple everyone
wants to happen i want it to happen they
have such chemistry together but what
makes it exciting is the chase right
like they set that up early in the
season them at this party then they gave
little breadcrumbs towards it happening
with her visiting him at his job but all
of a sudden she's at a base where she
can just text him and let's hang out and
go to his house like that felt
completely rushed here that she'd even
show up there like when did they get to
that level of comfort with each other it
feels out of whack like they skipped a
scene or two that was necessary for
these two to get to this point where she
would just call him and go to his house
so to me then the stand by me seen with
them singing together and then holding
hands falls flat because of that like i
feel like it wasn't earned enough yet
they had such a good pace with that and
that they dropped the ball because they
just kind of rushed it here that okay
now she's on terms with fez to just go
to his house a guy who's completely
opposite of her and how they live their
lifestyle that had to be something they
showed how it got there for her to
comfortably trust him and vice versa and
that happened but what this scene is
doing is story-wise clearly it's setting
up feds to have this nice joyful moment
where it's gonna happen right before
something awful with the cops is gonna
happen with pheasant ashtray now because
their partner basically is throwing the
shade towards them about the murder of
mouse so he's saying that he didn't get
down the cop's mind but clearly he's
lying and the cops probably were
accusing him and then he was like oh
it's these other people so this is
information that cherry knows i don't
know what she's gonna do we see her go
in the bathroom is she just gonna try to
run out of there or what or warren fez
who knows but it's not looking good for
fez at this point but then we see like a
lot of bad parenting in the show this
really happens with nate's mom here
where yes it's good she is honest with
nate about like the choking and that you
know he shouldn't do stuff like that and
that she really believes he did that but
what's not helpful to the situation is
her saying things like what went wrong
with you at such a young age like i
thought you got hit in the head that was
just brutal and even for someone like
nate you feel bad like it's just wrong
but what i did take from the scene too
is that she mentions she likes cassie
the best out of all nate's you know
flings and i think it's subconsciously
whether nate realizes or not we'll set
up by the end of this episode why nate
chooses to stick around with cassie
there's some influence there but my
favorite moment of this episode is from
roo's narration when they then cut to
jules laying on the bed and she's like
so with jules and elliot and then she's
like you know what i don't want to talk
about them f them that was great i
thought that was one of the funniest
scenes in euphoria ever so when nate
shows up to maddie's place with a gun we
get this classic shot where someone is
in someone's apartment and it's a mirror
shot of nate holding the gun something
like out of no country for old men this
is psychonate but where i get a little
annoyed is i don't know if this was a
misdirection by sam levinson or again
maybe maddie kind of dropped the ball
the actress here because when she
actually first sees a man even though
it's nate who she knows with a gun point
at her that she didn't know was in the
room point out she's not shocked at all
she's like what are you doing i thought
that was just the wrong reaction at that
point i didn't believe it at all i mean
how do you not you know scream or react
more and like panicked it was just what
are you doing i thought that was really
weird but crazy nate goes into full
effect here he does this fake rush
roulette on himself to scare maddie to
give him the tape why did maddie take so
long to just give him the tape maybe to
make a tense scene but again it's like i
i was confused by that too like just
give him the freaking tape like he's got
a gun to your head he should have gave
him the tape the minute he put it on her
head period and he mentions it was a
joke no bullets in the gun just
completely crazy person but we see now
nate shows up to jules she does the
right thing by grabbing a box cutter
before she sees him because you can
never trust nate but he's now
apologizing for the events of last
season this is way overdue to even be
addressed and he gives jules the tape he
actually does a good thing for once and
what's interesting he says the reason
i'm doing this would be too stupid and
simple to even say which i believe it's
his love for her that is the reason he's
doing it he's not saying it and we know
this too because he says before the near
go everything i ever said was true and
she says same here and remember the
happiest we've seen jules in any type of
relationship is with nate but when she
didn't know his nate and was just
texting a mystery person there was some
chemistry the two of them had texting
each other and they're both
acknowledging that here and then we'll
see he ends up here with cass he calls
cassie and he says come see me i love
you and it's important as they reunite
him and cassie that it cuts again to
that shot of maddie crying on her bed
curled up in a ball so showing you
they're finding this piece now finally
and love and maddie's on the outside
here crying but i still think that this
is just a reminder how maddie's affected
by this but i think it's going to turn
the tide towards hirakana directing that
anger again towards nate especially how
he treated her in this episode
threatening her like that and again
because she had this talk from samantha
about how she did something like cassie
again there's a reason for scenes like
this right it's to change the course of
where we think the show might go so this
is another situation where there's other
rumors about stuff that went on behind
the scenes with euphoria and again i'm
not someone who gives truth to rumors i
don't believe rumors they're rumors
because they're rumors right like
they're probably not true but there is
rumors about certain reasons why it
wasn't jules and cassie's shoes and the
story this season like and it's
interesting to think about that because
you're like it just would make so much
more sense this season if jewel's story
was cassie's story with nate it was set
up last season that way it'd be
consistent it wouldn't feel as forced in
as this cassian8 story because it just
makes so much more sense that nate you
know loves maddie but also has this love
for jewels and how it's so taboo and why
they didn't lean into that so i don't
know if any rumors are true but if they
are again it would make sense because
again this just doesn't feel like the
best choice to make it cassie having a
storyline over clearly i think a more
powerful story would have been jules and
nate in this situation so it's strange
and bizarre cause it's good but it's not
what it could be with this cassie and
nate's story because you you sit there
and see how good the scene was between
jules and nate in this episode and
wonder man wouldn't have been better if
we got a whole season of this and it
would have also brought rue more into
the fold because she's closer to jules
than she is to cassie period because
cassie's not a direct character
resulting roo's life it just would have
all worked better so maybe something
happened who knows so because we got
such a rue central episode last week
this episode doesn't have much rue they
only bookend the show with rue scenes
here and you know roo can't even treat
herself to a jolly rancher at the start
of this episode right she's still going
through these crazy withdrawals i think
it's a misdirect to the audience because
you're supposed to kind of think you
know is that her tempted is that a lace
jolly rancher i don't think that's what
was happening here i think that it was
her not even able to treat herself to a
piece of candy at this point right
there's so much guilt there as well with
rue she's facing all these demons that
she's talking about her narration to the
point we even see some zendaya boogies
here and what's interesting she's
reflecting about she doesn't remember
what she said to her mom but maybe some
of it was true if she said it she
doesn't know but she's happy she has a
forgetful mother and you're seeing
though she's saying this stuff like
believes the world will be better
without her that people also think that
and she talks about being a thief
abusive manipulative she feels the most
regret though out of all these things of
being what she said to ali and she says
it's reducing someone's life to one bad
moment i like this writing i think this
speaks to a lot that's happening in the
world today that we do that and she says
everybody does it right cops everyone
that we reduce just one bad thing
someone's done to their whole life story
so i like that they kind of address that
and it works really well with ali's
story and you know what she's not even
realizing she's doing a huge step in a
recovery process where she decides to
call ali and apologize and that's why i
think the jolly rancher was that moment
because once she apologized to lee she's
shocked he forgives her she actually has
a moment of self love by eating the
jolly rancher finally right when that
happens something she struggles with and
i love again i know i don't want to beat
a dead horse but zendaya's great raw
performance here just spectacular again
in this episode and you see ali combs
great actor coleman domingo always
retreat but he lightens the mood by
making these diarrhea withdrawal jokes
and he's having to make dinner but what
i like is they had ali's character
addressing what happens to gia here
right that she's suffering just as much
as rue and he believes it's better for
her to let her anger out she feels
towards where it's more healthier you
know than suppress that and we'll see
that's really paid off in the end of the
episode because in the dinner sequence
roo says at dinner she wants to get
clean right but what ali is doing here
with gia and the mom is he's encouraging
honest open talk here that it's
healthier to put it out on the table
than just say if she needs our support
no like air out the dirty laundry and a
great line ali says is the hope is what
rue has to find not people who support
her so if you know anything about
staying sober or someone you know had to
stay sober in your life it's not about
the people around them what they do it's
about it has to be the person who wants
to get clean has to be the person who
finds the hope in themselves period and
this is what he's alluding to again
really accurate writing and ali has the
best line to the mom here he's like let
ruby rue but shower that little one with
love she has been waiting on it really
good stuff makes it ali so much more
likable than he already is and it's just
gonna you know you see this chemistry
between him and the mom too i feel like
they're obviously gonna end up together
now i like this moment where gia goes
into the bed with rue and rue's like i
feel like i don't know anything about
your life anymore and g is like i'll
tell you when you get back so it's a
nice hopeful moment right and we get to
see them actually connect as humans for
once but the poor mother gets this call
that she can't have rue go into the
rehab the way she had planned it's just
they're not taking her that way but to
end the episode on this i don't know it
was just me but this felt extremely
anti-climatic like it ended on a whimper
and it now is feeding into my head that
fear i've had about the show now that
we're at the end of episode six only two
episodes left like does sam levinson
know where this is all going where are
we going you know is this show just a
giant circle you know is it gonna be rue
relapses and she gets sober and then she
realizes gets sober how is this gonna
stay interesting you know where what is
the next what am i looking forward to
now you know i don't really know i think
that's where the show suffers with its
writing is again there's not enough
conflict in the sense of waiting week to
week to see what's going to happen next
about a certain thing that's a challenge
right it's just kind of like okay is rue
gonna stay sober is she not you know so
i don't know i i feel like that's where
this show kind of falls flat and i've
pointed out my issues i've had with this
episode and i liked a lot too but this
was maybe i would say definitely
actually my least favorite of the season
i'm giving this one a 7.9 but it really
worries me now like maybe there isn't an
end vision for this show is going and it
just got renewed for season three which
is great but i'm just kind of curious
like what's next what what where is this
story possibly going i i don't know so
it's great character study it's great
character work but it needs interesting
plot as well that's part of the puzzle
and i think that's just suffering here
uh but let me know let me know what you
guys saw this episode what do you think
of the season so far i read every
comment i try to respond as many as i
can and if you really love what i do
here i appreciate you becoming a member
today it will support me to make more
videos for you guys you'll get special
perks as well please follow me at steve
steverlyshow on twitter instagram and
tick tock for more of me and i'll see
you next time